sweet potato is the one outlier that
actually is a french fry but is
completely Standalone and completely
uniquely different than the other seven
you can't that's right it's not even
based in that's right it's based in the
actual product but that's why it sucks
because you can't do anything with it
you can't do anything like that's unique
and original and and yeah I could I
could say uh oh you know I make uh I
make uh zucchini fries aren't they great
because it's zucchini I'm like no it
sucks here's why it sucks the sweet
potato fry I can't step into any of the
fun Realms that the other frats can step
into you dip a sweet potato frying
ketchup it's too much sugar it's too
sweet it's good it's too sweet you the
seasonings you love on uh on a curly fry
would would taste weird on a sweet
potato fry uh it's too much of its own
flavor versus the burger and everything
else that you're I hate it